[Musique]
le festival les images avaient fait la
gamme honda festival annuel que
l'association de contrechamp
l'association de programmation et
d'éducation à l'image dans 78 propose
donc
pour fêter le cinéma fait revivre les
cinémas sur le territoire nous sommes
tous et cette année c'est particulier
parce que c'est la dixième année est ce
qui est encore plus particulier c'est
que la précédente édition s'est faite en
ligne et là on va pouvoir enfin
rencontrer les spectateurs
ce court métrage vient alors de taper à
peu près partout on a eu des courts
métrages dont qui donnait d'angleterre
par exemple mais aussi des courts
métrages un peu plus près de région
parisienne mais aussi les courts
métrages qui viennent par exemple d'un
produit national de toulouse d'un peu
partout fait on voyage à travers ses
courts métrages
traitent soirée c'est une soirée donc de
compétition de courts métrages donc il
va se dérouler par un accueil du public
qui va pouvoir découvrir mes recours
métrage et donc il va pouvoir voter pour
le premier court métrage a découvert
découvrir aussi des jeunes talents et
pas pour pour ce vote donc pu y aura le
vote du public naturellement mais aussi
un jury professionnel qui sera
constituée pour voter et il y aura une
remise de clean numéraire donc aux
gagnants